in unserem nachbarland polen brodelt es
kaum eine woche ohne proteste auf den
straßen für gleiche rechte gegen
ausgrenzung
dabei lieben die protestierenden
gefährlich und hier sieht man die leute
die tatsächlich steine geworfen haben
vor der kirche wer gegen ausgrenzung
einsteht landet nicht selten vor gericht
wie hier
[Musik]
ein gutes madonnenbild ist in polen zum
streitfall geworden ich will wissen wie
schwer ist es hier aktivistin zu sein
ich bin auf dem weg nach polen genauer
gesagt nach platz da stehen drei frauen
vor gericht die ein bild der heiligen
madonna mit einem regenbogen faden
heiligenschein versehen und auch plakat
gedruckt haben ihre aktion richtete sich
gegen die katholische kirche
denn diese hatte die begriffe lgbt und
geschlecht zuvor mit sünden wie hass
oder verrat gleichgesetzt
für das aufhängen und verteilen ihrer
bunten madonnen plakate hier in plots
drohen den frauen nun bis zu zwei jahre
haft
ich habe eine drehgenehmigung für das
gericht will dabei sein wenn später das
urteil fallen soll
trotz eisiger kälte und schnee haben
sich am morgen der verhandlung schon
demonstrierende versammelt mit
regenbogen und laute musik
der konflikt um die regenbogenflagge ist
schon 2009 10 zum politikum geworden
der hashtag rainbow madonna verbreitet
sich im netz und es ist nicht der
einzige in den aktuellen polnischen
protestbewegung
drei kopiert frauenstreik lautet
überholen hinaus der hashtag gegen das
verschärfte abtreibungsgesetz der rote
blitz wird zum symbol des zorns auf die
katholische kirche und die
rechtskonservative regierungspartei pri
[Musik]
mitte 2009 10 entstehen diese bilder von
ausschreitungen auf der ersten gay pride
in polen und gehen sofort iran
[Musik]
transportiert in polen wirklich schlimm
das schlimmste in polen denke ich sind
die negative die von der regierung und
den medien verbreitet werden
das kann großen schaden anrichten und
lässt die leute denken dass sie ihre
feine sind wir sind nicht in der
situation von russland wo es für jede
positive erwähnung von lgbt themen eine
anzeige gibt man wird bestraft
aber zur gleichen zeit wird die luft
dünner und dünner
im gerichtsgebäude sitzen elf biotop
ortlechner und zwei andere aktivistinnen
die anklage lautet beleidigung
religiöser gefühle
mich interessiert warum in polen lgbt
feindlichkeit salonfähig zu sein scheint
so sehr dass gewalt gegen homosexuelle
und transport nicht bestraft wird
ich werde später noch jemanden treffen
der mir krasse bilder dazu zeigt erstmal
kontaktiere ich amnesty international
und lerne kevin von christian haring ist
polen in deutschland geboren
sie lebt in hamburg definiert sich als
kurier und bund ihre familie in polen
konnte sie von ihrem quer seien bisher
nie richtig erzielen
in einer kleinstadt kleinen dorf würde
ich das eher nennen und wenn du darauf
die straße gehen würde so wie auch jetzt
ich heute da wirst du einfach anders
angeschaut und da kannst du nicht
komplett du selbst sein
das ist ein von oben herab jemanden
anzusehen was er anhat und dadurch dass
ich mich immer gerne anders präsentiert
habe das irgendwie nach außen getragen
habe habe ich mich immer direkt
reduziert gefühl dieses versteckspiel
vor ihrer familie habe sie psychisch
krank gemacht erzählt kennen
dabei weiß ich schon seit ihrer
schulzeit dass sie auf frauen steht ja
es macht sich hier mit mir weil es
meiner identität abstreitet und
unabhängig von dem kurier seines einfach
mein main mensch
weil ich mich ja auch identifiziere
damit das heißt mein ganzes menschsein
ist quasi abgestritten
heute studiert karen religion dialog und
bildung ich finde das zeigt wie sehr sie
ihre eigene religiöse geschichte
umtreibt das hätte ich so nicht erwartet
ich will noch besser verstehen was es
heißt als lgbt person in polen zu leben
und fahre richtung osten nach who are
here hat der stadtrat einen offen homo
und transphobie erklärung unterzeichnet
diese charta der familien rechte soll
kinder vor homosexuelle propaganda und
moralischen verfall schützen kurve ist
damit eine von mittlerweile mehr als 50
zonen in polen die sich gegen die
sogenannte lgbt ideologie aussprechen
ich lerne ja bega und bogdan kennen
lange haben sie die katholische kirche
nicht in frage gestellt bis sie wieder
dort selbst ausgrenzen erlebt hat
seitdem ist ihr mehr toleranz schaffen
eine herzensangelegenheit
dies ist eine und hier ist mein ältester
sohn ja sie hat einen sohn aus dem lgbt
millionen er ist schwul
deshalb kämpfen sie hier ist mein sohn
der das interview gegeben hat bei sie
gesagt haben dass sie ihn nicht einmal
in ein restaurant lassen ja vegas sohn
thomas ist heute 44 jahre alt und lebt
in warschau
hier in prora sei er schrecklich
behandelt worden sagt die amiga der
priester habe ihn in der kirche
ignoriert
ein psychologe habe ja wieder sogar
geraten ihren sohn zu enterben
wenn er seine homosexualität nicht
behandeln lassen würde
ich bin gläubig ja wir sind gläubige wir
sind katholisch wir sind getauft wir
sind in diesem glauben erzogen aber im
moment gefällt mir überhaupt nicht was
los ist
wir sind zutiefst dagegen ein solches
klima der verachtung für andere menschen
zu schaffen
wir stehen für pro demokratische werte
gleichheit unabhängig von hautfarbe
religion oder sexueller orientierung
leider haben wir 2015 als die pis partei
die macht in polen übernahm schon
vermutet und geahnt dass es angriff auf
minderheiten andersgläubiger farbige
oder anders sexuell orientierte geben
wird vor allem diese gruppen werden
angetroffen
ja und das ist schrecklich schrecklich
jadwiga fühlt sich im stich gelassen und
ausgegrenzt von der kirche und der
regierung
seitdem setzt sie sich aktiv für mehr
toleranz in ihrem heimatland ein
polen ist ein sehr religiöses land 87
prozent der bevölkerung sind
römisch-katholisch im vergleich in
deutschland sind nur 27 prozent
katholiken
neben dem geistlichen beistand geben
kirche und katholische träger in polen
auch finanzielle hilfen zum beispiel für
schulen oder bedürftige und sie bieten
ganz praktische angebote
die bürgerberatung sportreisen und
bildung unterstützt von regierenden
politikern die werte der konservativ
nationalistischen pis regierung passend
zur haltung der katholischen kirche
gegen abtreibung und lgbt personen wie
verhärtet die fronten sind das werde ich
noch ziemlich genau erfahren
diese bilder sind 2009 10 auf der ersten
gay pride in polen entstanden sie zeigen
die aggressiv die stimmung in polen beim
thema lgbt ist gegen demonstranten
greifen die menschen ob der parade
brutalen steinen feuerwerkskörpern und
flaschen
gefilmter das ganze ein bekannter
polnischer aktivist mit dem ich noch
verabredet bin
wer will mit zeigen welche hass ihm und
anderen lgbt personen entgegen schlägt
aber erst mal zurück zur rolle von
kirche und politik eine polnische
journalistin hilft mir kontakt zum
stadtrat von bioware herzustellen der
die sogenannte familienvater mit
abgesegnet hat ignaz schick zeigt mir
stolz das museum der stadt und nachdem
ich ihn frage warum der katholische
glaube hier so groß geschrieben ist gibt
er mir religiösen geschichtsunterricht
die beziehung zwischen kirche und staat
sie sind wie zwei getrennte körper
unabhängig und doch wie pole glieder die
leuchten wenn sie nebeneinander stehen
diese mentalität der polen zu verstehen
müssen wir zu ihrer geschichte zurück
kehren zu ihren wurzeln
ich kenne kein anderes land das durch
die geschichte der katholischen religion
so sehr geprägt wurde
wer jesus nicht liebt könne polen nicht
verstehen sagt die glatze das zeigt wie
sehr der katholische glaube in der
polnischen kultur wurzeln geschlagen hat
und nicht nur dort bis heute auch in der
politik ich will wissen warum sich der
stadtrat offen gegen lgbt person
ausspricht in unserem brief fiel kein
wort über lgbt darum appelliere ich an
die eltern und lehrer unsere bildung zu
unterstützen weil wir das meiste geld
empor was für bildung ausgeben
50 prozent dieser ausgaben bezahlen wir
aus eigener tasche heißt also sowas wie
wer zahlt bestimmt die glatze erklärt
mir noch das lgbt eine ideologie sei und
dass man die nicht in die öffentliche
lehre ein
könne und dann sinkt ihr ein ständchen
was auch immer er damit sagen will ich
glaube es ist kein kompliment an die
moderne frau seine weltanschauung ist
jedenfalls weit von meiner entfernt
ich frage mich warum die katholische
kirche die ausgrenzung friedlich leben
der menschen offenbar aktiv unterstützt
michael sie dort ist 29 streng
katholische priester und hat einem
treffen mit mir zugestimmt
es ist bekannt dass es menschen gibt die
unterschiedliche sexuelle orientierungen
haben homosexuelle orientieren
solche menschen sind nicht unerwünscht
und von der kirche ausgeschlossen
dabei menschen die homosexuelle
beziehungen eingehen denen ein sündiges
leben ein und wir als priester und die
kirche haben die aufgabe sünde auf sünde
zu nennen
als priester können wir sie nur
ermutigen ein leben ohne sünde zu
bestreiten
jeder von uns hat einen freien willen
gott gab uns den freien willen grund
entscheidungen zu treffen entweder folge
ich gott oder ich wende mich von gott ab
er sagt mir noch schwul lesbisch bi
queer trans sein darf man nur ausleben
dürfen uns nicht macht für mich keinen
sinn für michael aber schon denn das
würde die religiösen gefühle von
katholiken beleidigen erklärt er
vor kurzem gab es sogar in unserer
kirche ein mann in der zweiten bank mit
der lgbt flagge auf seiner maske niemand
hat ihn gebeten die kirche zu verlassen
niemand hat ihn stigmatisiert aufgrund
der tatsache dass jeder mensch und
katholik das recht hat seine ansichten
und gefühle auszudrücken
wenn wir jedoch die kirche mit einer
solchen flagge auf der maske betrieben
stellt diesen gewisser weise auch eine
provokation da viele solcher
provokationen haben kürzlich im
polnischen kirchen stattgefunden und
bischöfe und priester zum eingreifen zu
provozieren
später wird dies dann von den medien
aufgenommen und so dargestellt als seien
wir gegen die lgbt bewege mich anruft in
seinen predigten auf familie zu schützen
mann und frau als einheit nur so könne
die menschheit fortbestehen und er wird
gehört mit seinen 29 jahren schließlich
setzte sich auch aktiv für familien ein
und vor allem mit angeboten für kinder
und jugendliche seine art ist mir
sympathisch seine glaubenssätze sehe ich
kritisch
ich bin schon vor einigen jahren aus der
kirche ausgetreten
auch wenn ich gut verstehen kann warum
menschen an gott glauben kann ich nicht
verstehen
inwiefern diversität eine gefahr für
jemanden darstellen soll
was meint ihr dazu schreibt es mir in
die kommentare zurück zur aktivistinnen
seite und nach warschau
ich bin mit bartoszewski verabredet das
ist der der die heftigen videoaufnahmen
mit gewalt gegen lgbt personen
veröffentlicht hat
[Musik]
wo genau erlebt das soll ich nicht
zeigen zu gefährlich sagt er und zeigt
mir nachher auch warum
bad ischl lebt seine beziehung mit
seinem freund offen
und er hat sich etwas ausgedacht um ein
zeichen gegen die lgbt freien städte zu
setzen
sie waren so stolz darauf diese lgbt
freien zonen zu haben also habe ich
gedacht was kann ich tun
okay ich mache und weise dieser orte mit
meinem schild aus ich habe nur dieses
eine schuld ich hänge es unter das
ortsschild der stadt oder der provinz
die diese schreckliche haltung
deklarieren
dann dachte ich noch dass es gut wäre
menschen neben diesem schild stehen zu
haben die tatsächlich lgbt sind und in
diesem zug
davon hat bator stand fotos gemacht und
die gegenwehr aal barsch ist mit seiner
fotoaktion aus über 50 lgbt freien zonen
über polen hinaus bekannt geworden
[Musik]
es war schwer leute für diese aktion zu
finden weil es in polen braucht offen
schwul zu sein
ich habe trotzdem einige gefunden und
sie haben sich mein projekt
angeschlossen
viele der anderen bilder sind aber leer
da ist also nur das ortsschild mit dem
namen der stadt drauf und das erzählt
auch eine wache abholen
dass die menschen angst haben sich in
solchen aktionen zu haben denn den
fotografierten könnte das gleiche wie
beim strom anzeige bei der polizei vor
allem von politikern rechtsnationaler
parteien sagt er
die behaupten sein schild wäre ein groß
angelegter angriff auf die gesellschaft
[Musik]
ich habe viel gerichtsverfahren und
circa 16 laufende polizeiliche
ermittlungen die im gerichtsverfahren
enden können wegen verstoßes gegen die
straßenverkehrsordnung
ich akzeptiere keine art von strafe die
sie mir auferlegen wollen ich erscheine
lieber vor gericht
viele dieser gelben flaggen können vor
gericht enden in den verschiedenen
teilen polens denn es wird alles in
verschiedenen gerichten sein
ich wohne in warschau also liegt wieder
eine sehr lange reise zu diesen ort
informieren um mich vor gericht zu
treffen und ich hoffe dass es nicht so
lange dauern wird
bartosch zeigt mir noch seine fotos hier
ist der pianist of pride wo es gewaltig
die leute haben sogar stein auf uns
geworfen und hier sieht man die leute
die tatsächlich diese steine vor der
kirche treffen haben während er diese
bilder gingen auch in polen viral das
war 2009 10 das gleiche jahr in dem sie
diese schrecklichen zu deklarieren
wir konnten also den realen effekt sehen
wie die menschen von den politikern
beeinflusst wurden
die ihnen sagen dass wir eine art
ideologie sind und sie das land vor uns
verteidigen müssen
hier haben wir einen typen der ein t
shirt mit der aufschrift jol ist gegen
die perversen trägt sie zünden die lgbt
flagge an und er zeigt mit dem finger
auf mich dass ich der nächste sein kann
es war also furchtbar es war ein drama
an das sich jeder von uns erinnert
diejenigen die dabei waren noch mehr
weil es ein trauma ist
was passieren kann in einer gesellschaft
in der hasco phobie und mobbing zum
alltag geworden zu sein scheint zeigt
bartosch mehr als nächstes diese drei
jugendlichen schwul und trans haben sich
das leben genommen
der junge in der mitte hat sich erhängt
keiner solle um ihn weinen schrieb er
kurz davor
er wäre ihn wertlos und das ist die
trans aktivistin den warschau von der
brücke gesprungen ist zu ihrem gedenken
hat bartosch eine trauer aktion auf
einer warschauer brücke veranstaltet und
selbst dort bleiben hass und gewalt
gegen sie nicht aus man kann sehen wie
gewalttätig sie waren und wie sie auf
eine friedliche versammlung reagiert
haben badisch filmt alles mit seiner
drohung die polizei konnte ihn nicht für
irgendetwas anklagen homophobie ist kein
verbrechen in polen
sie können die nur für die gewalt er den
menschen angetan hat anklang
die bilder und videos die bardusch mir
zeigt habe ich so vorher im netz nicht
gesehen
[Musik]
findet das weingut auf einmal war das
hat mir ziemlich deutlich gemacht wie es
ist für den aktivisten hier in polen die
das leben ist wie gefährlich es ist und
es ist offensichtlich ganz gefährlich
[Musik]
ich bin zurück am gericht hier soll
jetzt gleich das urteil fallen
zur erinnerung es geht um das
madonnenbild die urheberinnen elzbieta
potash und zwei weitere aktivistinnen
müssen sich wegen öffentlicher
beleidigung religiöser gefühle
verantworten
für den priester von klotz ist der
regenbogen auf der heiligen madonna wie
hakenkreuze neben der mutter gottes sagt
er
er vergleicht einen regenbogen mit nazi
symbolen die schlussplädoyers der
aktivist innen sind dementsprechend
emotional für sie steht viel auf dem
spiel
bis zu zwei jahre haft
das ist auch politisch das war eine
politische entscheidung denen diese
aktivisten vorzugehen und anklage zu
erheben erklärt mir eine der anwältin
und dann geht es ganz schnell
das gericht vertagte die verhandlung die
entscheidung sei zu kompliziert und
später verspricht mir gleich noch ein
interview
draußen aber erst mal will sie die
demonstrierenden nicht länger warten
lassen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich mache das schon seit fünf jahren
ohne eine einzige pause
es ist nicht letzten monat passiert es
begann von mindestens fünf jahren
und ich würde sagen dass die bisherigen
jahre den boden bereitet haben dass die
pis partei gewinnt und die einzige
opposition sitzt nicht im parlament
sondern ist auf der strasse politischen
stil und grasser und die menschen sind
sehr müde
wir glauben nicht mehr an die politiker
weil weil sie uns nicht helfen
sie sind an ihren kämpfen und profiten
und arbeitsplätzen interessiert und
nicht an den menschen auf der straße
[Musik]
ich bin beeindruckt davon wie sich wie
viel kraft sie hat was sie dafür eine
rede geschrieben hat egal ob ich das
verstanden habe oder nicht man hat
gemerkt dass power dahinter und ist es
auch toll zu sehen dass du dass deine
community dahinter ist die das
unterstützt ich finde viel viel zu klein
und deswegen
ich glaube ich auch gut dass man es in
die welt hinausträgt und hier zumindest
ja
und jetzt ist eure meinung gefragt
gerade ist das urteil gefallen die drei
frauen sind freigesprochen
findet ihr dass gerecht und wie schätzt
ihr den einfluss der katholischen kirche
in deutschland ein
schreibt mir in die kommentare lasst uns
gerne diskutieren